I mean it it doesn't make sense I'm glad
we made it but some still [__]
pissing me off it's like how the [__] do
they keep finding us how do they all
know our location
oh [__] uh
p i I gotta tell you something
your mom has been tracking your location
what whoa your mom's the rat dude you
think definitely dude he just said it I
don't know my mom's a rat she's the
definitely the rat you guys don't think
she would do that to me right you should
kill her Peter
Camila talk to you a minute
what's up what's up
you can kill your mom your mom is a
[__] rat I don't know what to do
shut the [__] up what are you [__]
stupid yes yeah I think so I want to
show you something
look at these pictures
every place we went to Paparazzi over
there look at everybody's face how
surprised they shocked we all were not
this big fat [__] look at his face he
looks happy what do you mean what's
wrong with that what's wrong with that
that's your [__] red he's like he
knew there was going to be Paparazzi
here he looks like he's ready to walk
the [__] red carpet like he's gonna
win a [__] Emmy or something Gilly
Sarah that's your [__] rat what do I
do I can't take care of everything for
you you just get rid of them that's all
thanks Pop you're uh you're part of the
crew now I don't want to be part of your
crew [__] your crew just just do this
take care of your own [__] all right
can I talk to you for a sec
yeah it's like over there in private
yeah
what's up dude what's up dude me I know
it was you [__] I didn't do it you sold
me out I didn't sell you out did you
sold me out my puppy told me you sold me
out you're gonna listen to that guy yeah
why because he's my [__] grandfather
what the [__] is that dude why would he
lie what'd you do I didn't do anything
just tell me what you did
all right
it's a girl with the Daily Mail
you got a weird thing going I want to
[__] have sex with her dude
so I told her where you were a bunch
that's what I'm worth you saw me out for
a [__]
who's head
do not let this ruin our [__] our
future together dude what you know what
we started from the bottom dude and now
we're here here he did it I've known you
for like three months I was pretty low
dude that was my bottom dude it's over
dude don't [__] tell anybody about
this don't tell Chris Evans don't
[__] touch your phone dude do not
tell Chris Evans about this I just told
him Chris dude it's over go home we're
friends dude we're like tight friends
dude it's not about friends
it's about family
you're not family don't get the [__] out
of here
[Music]
under this roof We Gather
to let you go
you brought us back together one last
chance to steal the show
you drew Us in with Love Like Moths To
Your naked flame
somehow this road we traveled we'll
never